hey klicken also meine Frage ist ob das
gleiche also dieser Supergau der in
Japan passieren könnte oder passieren
wird wahrscheinlich und das auch in
Deutschland passieren wird weil ich
meine Merkel hat ja vor die
Atomkraftwerke abzuschließen und dann
sind ja die Brennstäbe irgendwie die
können ja dann schmelzen was was würde
denn passieren wenn wenn die
ausgeschaltet werden könnte denn könnte
dann bei uns so etwas passieren wie bei
denen passieren würde wenn man ein
Kernkraftwerk abschaltet dann führt das
erstmal zu höherer Sicherheit weil das
Kernkraftwerk dann schon mal auf
Sparflamme läuft aber die Sparflamme ist
natürlich immer noch so stark äh dass
man die die Hitze die da entsteht die
war ja auch nicht die kann man nicht
abschalten dass man diese Hitze irgendwo
hinbringen muss und den bringt man dann
mit Wasser weg und kühlt damit und und
und heizt damit möglicherweise die Luft
oder ein Fluss aber jedenfalls man kühlt
diese Restwärme äh es ist also nicht so
dass jedes abschalten zu einer
Kernschmelze führt sondern das
Abschalten ist erstmal notwendig um auch
Kernschmelzen zu verhindern und dann
muss man noch das restfeuer ausmachen
und dies restfeuer ausmachen das macht
im Augenblick den Japanern die
Schwierigkeit und in Deutschland wie in
jedem normal funktionierenden
Kernkraftwerk äh auch international gibt
es für solche solche solche Situationen
immer Kühlsysteme und zwar nicht nur
eins sondern zwei und drei damit wenn
eins ausfällt das nächste noch
funktioniert
damit kann man dann auch diese nach dem
Abschalten eines Reaktors die Wärme die
sonst zum Kernschmelzen führte
beseitigen nur diese ganzen Sicherungen
haben jetzt in Japan nicht
gehalten